[Music]
thank you so much for joining us as our
first view from the top Speaker of the
year as you can see by all the students
here we are very excited to have you
so dean levin mentioned the fact that
you were born in mexico and you grew up
as the eldest of nine siblings in a
working-class family in southern
california how has that experience
shaped you yeah I was probably I was one
of the original dreamers right before
they had cool names for it but let's be
clear they did have names for it they
weren't very very nice I think I think
environment I think how you grow up
who you grow up with as a meaningful
impact on who you are as a person
there's a lot of you in this room you've
all had very different upbringing and I
know from my heritage in particular I
think the Latino population is one
that's very family-oriented humble in
general and again more importantly just
loyal sometimes to a fault and that is
all shaped me and then the hard work
aspect of that and so you know it's just
those those are my foundations I didn't
know to do anything else you know the
concept of entitlement when you're an
original dreamer not particularly strong
in your world so that did shape me who I
am and it does affect how I make
decisions to this very day I think I
make a lot of decisions we as a
corporation make a lot of decisions that
are founded on some of that upbringing
that I have and like some of the
students in the audience today you were
also the first in your family to go to
college and you were deciding between
some great universities the Stanford of
the East as Dean Levin how to quickly
put it and USC you chose USC where the
Boston winters too cold well on the on
the west coast there was a better
football program at the time clearly not
the case now
no you know what the story behind that
is again being a first-generation which
I hear some of you in the room our first
generation undergrads raise your hand
huge respect guys it's some big
responsibility for you and your families
but not knowing I mean literally the way
I chose I decided that I had to go to
college I was walking down the hallway
late to a class and mrs. Duckworth one
of our high school counselors stopped me
and said are you Oscar and it's like oh
crap I'm in trouble because why Alice
the high school counselors stop you
right we ate just taken those pSATS or
whatever and she goes where are you
thinking of going to college my answer
was honest to goodness what's a college
I might bring him my neighborhood it
wasn't just the Latino thing it was just
just where we lived it just wasn't
something you did you went to high
school you got married you had kids and
you lived happily ever after and that
was great but this offered me insight
and the view and to this day I hold her
and high degree of respect and give her
a lot of comfort to take me down that
path she helped me with applications and
all sorts of things to get there and
that's how I decided to go to college
now the choice of where and where that
was just my story of when I went to the
other school was just hilarious joke I
mean talk about to country rubes I grew
up in Hines in Beach I was a surfer kid
right I mean imagine Harvard Yard and
somebody in shorts flip-flops a t-shirt
and hair down to here with a blue collar
dad with just we were just even then at
a young age I knew that you have to find
your way find your spot and go there and
that just didn't feel like the way no
regrets
I know it was yes he was great yeah and
you had a heart attack 38 days after
taking over as the CEO and I did
got to cover the personal gonna cover
the personal oh yeah that was
interesting and you then had a heart as
a career thing I don't recommend that
yeah and then you would have a heart
transplant on your birthday in early
2016
yeah so this Saturday night this last
couple Monday's ago the 15th of October
marked the third year that my third
anniversary of having the actual heart
attack and we always we don't celebrate
it as much but it gets raised it's an
emotional day because you realize what
you have versus what but could have been
I might be here
this coming Saturday night my my
transplant doctor my cardiologist and
some of my very close friends and of
course my family we're celebrating the L
and John has gone his last tour and so
we're celebrating something on that
regard but yeah the 37 that was that was
crazy life is in all our plans and all
the things that you're doing are
wonderful I'm telling you you know you
hear all these axioms and all these
superlatives and broad majors about
lived life to its fullest and you know
bolo you only owe Yolo and you know what
there's a degree of truth to those
things you never know what's gonna
happen and that was my that was my
situation but yeah 37 days and then the
transplant on my on my on my birthday
there's a degree of fortunate of
blessings of being lucky they're
important in life and I am all of those
in a damn glad to be here as they say
yeah so how have your perspectives and
behaviors change day to day they really
haven't I think I do appreciate life in
general more and there's moments of sort
of personal emotion and drama when I
celebrate anniversaries like that or why
I have to tell a story or I have to
visit someone in the hospital that's
going through something like that it's a
it's not only a physical issue with you
personally it also is emotional and then
it impacts all your loved ones and it's
important I think to keep a very
positive attitude so all of that I do a
lot more
hospitals literally all over the world
and I'll see folks and talk to them just
by the nature of what I do and my usual
energetic rambling self people look it's
like hey you looks normal and when they
know what I've been through it's a it's
a bit of a motivator for people to get
out of there
out of their funk because I'm Tanya
doctors are very conservative and
they'll tell you all of these things you
shouldn't do like I shouldn't be in any
enclosed spaces with a lot of people
airplanes
I shouldn't be you know hanging around
with it's like everything I'm not
supposed to do
I couldn't possibly live without doing
and that's my choice and my doctors
generally keep up with me but it is an
important part of again back to the
question you asked earlier with regards
to you know who you are as a person it
it does it things like that shape you
would change you but Who I am how I
approach things that had nothing to do
with it and I ask that all my loved ones
like have I changed and I'm like no
you're still the same crazy person that
I've always been yeah so I want to talk
about sort of how your personality and
that that thinking and that process led
you to take the role at United so when
you took over as CEO you and you
inherited a company that was still
struggling to overcome some of the
challenges from the merger with
Continental and it's not common for
airline CEOs to come from outside of the
industry why did you believe it was the
right job for you I think it's back to
my fundamental foundation of who I am
and what I think I can do and advice I
give to all of you you really have to
know who you are it's y'all know thyself
thing and and I always did know thyself
, and then I write a really big really
with an exclamation point not though not
the self that you think and you want to
project to others that you are the real
self the real self and in the middle of
the night your minds going we are all
Petty and jealous and greedy and angry
all of those things those are pure
wonderful human qualities the more you
understand yourself the more you know
your pet election in those areas I'm
telling you it's the best of yourselves
when you know that I think part of
mature
I think part of growing up I think of
part of having success you're able to
have these conversations and I'm telling
you know yourself really and when you do
and so back to the application of me I
know what I love I know what I like and
I love the work that we were doing at
the railroad but it was a railroad it
was a b2b was Freight
it was very industrial very labor
oriented we taken we had great runs as
the Dean mentioned with regards to what
we have done financially but there was
always something missing for me and I
missed the things from my coca-cola and
Pepsi Cola days branding mechanism
marketing connecting with other humans I
thought that was really important and
more importantly being on the board I
saw some of the frustration in our
employee base I saw some of the firm's
with precision with her customers and I
certainly saw where again back to
knowing myself what do I get the most
energy from well it is capturing the
hearts and minds of many many folks in a
large organization and I'm thinking I
can do that and then I had a couple
board members who were really
instrumental in another sort of
initiative objective of mine in my life
is how do you make a difference in this
world and what from what platform can
you make it and we all have different
platforms and we can all do different
goods in different areas but taking a
big brand like United Drive in a turn
around having success gives you a
platform to really advocate to really do
good things for the community do good
things for the environment for you know
you name it I now have a voice on a
platform that I wouldn't have without
that and one of our board members a guy
named Walter Isaacson you guys may have
heard of them arguably the best living
American writer today he called me in
from two hours he just berated me about
taking this role because I was literally
going to be the CEO at this next company
and I'm like in days and he's like you
have the opportunity Oscar to changed
the face of American capitalism and that
was like you know that's only something
something like an author of his renown
would say and I'm like well dang I'm so
good I'm just hoping to get free flights
or something
but when he said that and it's actually
sparked a lot of conversations that I've
had not only with my employees but in
general I like to say things like we're
building a company that's not only
profitable but principles and that you
can be both and more importantly that by
being principled you can actually be
even more profitable and as you guys get
into your careers you're starting mid or
beginning to reach from school back into
the work it is becoming an ever
increasing level of attention from the
new generation that you bring right it's
not just the products not the what you
do like we do to perform but it's also
the how you do it and I think I can do
both and and so that was an opportunity
that I think I had at United that I may
or may not have had really at CSX cuz
you probably wouldn't have me here if I
was at CSX just saying I think no well
dr. Parker knows me so maybe I would be
I want to come back to the platform
discussion in a little bit but the the
phrase that you use the road to changing
the face of American capitalism that
road hasn't been the smoothest Road
aside from the personal challenge we
call it turbulence yes exactly
when there are a series of incidents
last year including the forced removal
of a passenger on a United flight and
separately the deaths of animals on on
United flights and I guess what I'm
curious about is what lessons you've
publicly acknowledged and apologized for
this and on many occasion but for the
students what lessons have you learned
through that experience first and
foremost and when we talked beforehand
little ISM and Patrick I said there's
nothing off the table ask me whatever
the heck you want period it's like there
is nothing that I'm anything about and
because everything we do is learning
there is turbulence and everything that
we do that situation has sparked what I
believe will be the major cog and
United's turnaround over time is that it
got our collective stuff together
about we we are such a big company with
big operational requirements where
safety and security have to be art
topmost
that's right um it has to be policies
and procedures are rigorous they're
demanding and more importantly they're
constrictive and they don't give you a
lot of room for what we are trying to
build now which is a caring culture and
so in that particular instance the
learning was we let our policies and
procedures get in the way of doing the
damn right thing right who in their
right mind would bring in police and
that we all saw the video right I mean
500 million views in China I was out
visiting and I'm like that's boy that
doesn't teach you something it does but
it was a catalyst to what we've
established from that point forward
we've established so many more customer
oriented our philosophy in our next
journey after we've done what we've done
so far is I want to make you we want to
make you feel better about flying us
that mean I put that in your spreadsheet
you can't but you can because if you
think about how we built this company to
this day inside the ride the first thing
I did is I regain the trust of my
employees that was my first big saying
to Wall Street on Wall Street went just
apoplectic like what the hell does that
mean
he's from outside the industry doesn't
know what the hell he's doing and the
first thing he says he's gonna be nice
to people you know and and what is that
gonna how is that what's the return on
that well you fast forward a year later
our operations are you settled our union
contracts our operations are doing best
we bled the last two years and on on
time origination we're getting our
planes out on time and we haven't
invested a huge amount of money we've
invested in human capital right and
getting those trust so build the trust
of employees get that right build your
operations then build a strategy a
business strategy which all of you love
right we're all that's the sexy part
that sexy part eight don't work without
the human capital underneath it and
that's another thing that we always
forget is that trust me in that large an
organization that's so spread all over
the Oliver God's green earth literally
because we're a global company you have
to get that right and then build from
that and so that's the foundation for
the things that we've been doing and
this next journey is about the customer
making you feel better and that is
probably the most arduous and difficult
thing because it's hard to measure you
tell me every day
you can tell me I mean MPs it's such a
hard thing because if your coffee wasn't
the right temperature if somebody's
sitting next to you had a dog that was
the size of Bosnia I mean I'm gonna get
in trouble for saying but nothing
against Bosnia but they're saving all of
you our frequent fliers you all have
your views about what's right
we're chatting in the back about if I
ever write a book I'm gonna title that
there is no good deed that goes
unpunished in this business because if I
do something for customers Wall Street
gets upset if I do something for Wall
Street employees and customers get upset
if I do something for so it's always
this constant thing and you're a
demanding wonderful crowd and so by it
my thing I would tell you is that people
like to catch you in these kind of
conversations especially on national TV
well Oscar don't you think the
customer's always right and I said you
know what unfortunately in this day and
age safety and security are paramount
and to the extent that we can after
taking care of those two we want to put
you at the center of everything we do
and that's a difficult task but you have
to understand safety and security are
key I'd love to have you just show up at
the airport and get on any damn plane
you want yeah come on in get on
Southwest does that I think sorry
he's gonna come after me so we live with
word gosh we've got so much to do still
yeah and how do you balance that that
what you just discuss so investing in a
better customer experience while
maintaining the cost discipline required
for profitability in the short term
expectations from Wall Street and a
highly competitive industry how do you
balance that see this is where these are
the things that you need you we need to
learn more of even at this relatively
young edge so I call that debate NPS you
know a net promoter versus EPS because
in our world that's the trade-off
I mean it's sometimes you just have this
decision where do I put more seats in
the airplane well you don't like that
but it you know density and overhead
absorption and all the things that we
know makes sense for us so how do we
balance those two things well you there
trade-offs and more importantly for us
at United what we're doing is we're
listening to you our customers like
what's important to you does this matter
to you does it really do how do we do
this remember we roll things out we test
it with a lot of different folks we just
introduced something called better
boarding and you're like how boring is
that right boarding really well it's one
of the highest stress points how do I
know that I asked you and it's going
like gangbusters what you went from five
to two and everybody's gone from two to
three and a half that nobody's done this
all the time what they haven't done the
secret sauce of why ours is working as I
spent my team spent eight months working
with customers and with gate agents who
do what oh yeah they do this for a
living every single day they know how
things board and what works and what
doesn't so are really smart people would
do it flows and the regressions and the
statistical analysis that says this or
that the first sign of a plan first
falls apart at the sign of the enemy and
for us the enemy is our own people's
like this is stupid this doesn't work
why don't we try this why don't we try
that and so the concept of involving
folks is it requires patience it
requires you putting your ego and your
intelligence often aside right you're
all kind of come out of here with a
Stanford degree guide you guys have had
a massive leg up but if you go back in
your workplaces what I call all asses
and elbows right
they'll blowing people out of the way
because you're so damn smart I'm telling
you one of the things that we learn as
we gain more experience one of the
saddest things that you have is middle
to senior middle managers who lament the
fact that their careers have not gone
like they planned and they look around
and everybody else I'm so smart I'm so
capable no one recognises that ladies
and gents on you it is a meritocratic
world out there people noticed quality
people notice leadership people rewarded
to this very day there's pockets with
bias and and and racial things and then
sex Allison no question but in general
as a whole people to get ahead because
you've made an effort to get ahead and
that's and all those axioms about
treating others and not having an agenda
and working all that sort of thing but
it's the saddest thing when people are
that age and they just haven't figured
out the EQ side of things you have to
make yourself the kind of person that
people are willing to come up to and
provide advice and I run a really big
company and you'd be appalled at some of
the conversations that people have with
me when someone's upset they will yell
at me they will stand there and they'll
do this and I'm loving every minute of
it because at the end of the day sharing
is caring right and if you're yelling at
me I still have a shot at you it's like
and and that has made the biggest
difference in our company because they
know they can have that output but and
then once you do that you can you begin
to capture hearts and minds and then
when you ask them to ask them to do and
we ask ourselves to do things it's a lot
easier way of doing it so it's a long
question to a one I don't even remember
what you have okay so I do have to admit
to the audience that I am a United
loyalist and status status holder I I
know I know I know firsthand how a mode
is from Boston the first thing I
questions like why do you have a
hyphenated last name that was actually
his first question today another trick
to interviews always turn the tape yes I
do know firsthand how emotive and even
tribal people can be about their
Airlines however some have had as we've
discussed some very negative experiences
with United and some have even stated
that they would quote unquote never fly
the airline again why should they
reconsider a a funny thing so I over
time you get to know people everywhere
and some of the SNL cast I become
friendly with and everybody knows we can
update right if you go back to the time
when they they reported on the DAO
incident that's the flight what we had
to that flight earlier in the week that
somebody had found a scorpion and one of
our overhead bins and so he leads Yost
leads with this and tonight in the news
you're not airlines have you know found
of you know scorpion another thing and
he's like many kind of smells nice
thinking but honestly that wasn't the
worst news of the week for United and
they were briefed and meant just
mentioned it they were very nice to us
they just mentioned it briefly as they
do for everyone else and then he stares
into the camera because I won't never
fly images with the serious face pause
pause until they have a good price to
wherever I want to go then of course
there's a guy that really used to run
Spirit Airlines which he he would carry
around these twelve letters and he'd
open one of the letter and to be
somebody saying I'll never fly this
airline ya know this and and the
remaining eleven letters were from the
same customer over the course of two or
three years the economic impact that the
price of things makes it makes
difference to all of us there's no
question you may not fly someone again
whatever people are very emotional about
this business it's very personal to them
which is why our purpose and mission is
about connecting people not the physical
connection from point A to point B but
connecting you as a human being just
something that's really important to you
somewhere else and that's the foundation
of our shared purpose then again back to
my previous come involved ninety
thousand people telling me telling us
what was important to them so connecting
people in that more you know personal
way and then uniting the world which is
an interesting thing that came out
because it's really led me and us to be
able to do a lot of you know take stands
in and docket dreamers the you know
separation of children gun control and
some of the issues that survived there
because you know when you have a shared
purpose that's uniting in the world that
you're 90 thousand employees I told you
it gives you a responsibility to take
action and and take a position on some
of those things so so what a transition
to speaking about some of the management
and leadership challenges and and some
of the things that you've done recently
many do not realize that the flight
attendant crews from the United
Continental merger continued to work
separately for over eight years
that is until earlier this month when
you successfully finalize the deal with
the unions how did you succeed in
reaching a deal after so long and can
you share some negotiating tips with us
so the actual contractual deal was
signed a couple years ago when we agreed
on the contract implementing the
contract was what was just transpired
you had 26,000 people flight attendants
who are the front the face the you know
the brand to some degree coming from
two different cultures all of you will
study mergers and acquisitions we'll do
all the math the synergies how costs can
be down more all the things that we like
to do the human integration of different
cultures along with the systems that
support them are very critical and how
you handle those and how you manage them
because there's so much more pride and
so much more history and so much more
resistance to change in those kind of
mergers and integrations so it took us a
while the contract had been going on for
five years and when I came it's just my
style I had I had this is where history
will always follow you so I had spent 10
plus years at a railroad
where we were largely Union oriented and
unions tend to be headed by the same
people across on a national level when a
union from one company when you switch
to other company calls the Union people
the other company and say that's a good
guy he's gonna work with you huge huge
benefit to starting a question so I
don't make that up I don't do that it's
just the way I work and the way you work
with people now my dad was a union meat
cutter my uncle was headed the IBEW in
California it started unions in Los
Angeles would literally when there was
people were getting killed for
organizing things so I grew up in that
environment I've seen the value of it to
some degree I also see some of the
deficiencies as we move forward but
nevertheless it's the world they've
chosen and you have to admire you have
to respect it more importantly you have
to acknowledge it right seek first to
understand then to be understood and we
don't do that your Union guy you clearly
don't have my best interest in mind you
know what
try it and and I think once you build
that a little bit of that history it
made a difference when we came to United
and we settled that five-year contract
in one year and it wasn't you serious it
wasn't you know given everything away we
have a very fair contract for both which
is the way it should be right fair day's
pay for a fair day's work and the only
thing that needs to be negotiated is
what a fair day and what is fair pay
ladies and gentlemen there's many books
written on that but having a
relationship to start the conversation
is much easier than not in my mind
so being located in Silicon Valley
Stanford students are often drawn into
the startup and the technology companies
in this area after graduation
but why should we consider working for a
more established company such as united
instead um well again back to the
concept of know thyself what makes you
tick if you're just following parent
again I have to be careful because my
children have all become bankers and
consultants not that anybody wants to do
that here in tech is a great space and
if you're good at it you really love it
and it's something you want to do and it
really make motivation get you going go
do that thing the sooner you learn that
what you love and what you want to do
and what makes you passionate and you go
do that I'm telling you you're young you
have lots of life left you go do
something just for the money just cuz
what's your friend that's just currently
what's hot you'll wake up sometime in
that career and say oh dang it I wish I
had done something else so again back to
nobody knows yourself better than you
than you and so think hard about those
things and that's what you want to do
wonderful go do it it's all great
training ground but sometime between
it's kind of like choosing a major in
undergrad right go try all the different
things but some point in time the school
calls you the Dean call you say dude you
gotta pick life won't tell you that
they'll let you in life will let you go
on but at some point in time your
personal well-being how you reflect with
the people around you how you how you're
productive to your community and more
importantly how you interact with your
loved ones and you all have loved ones
it makes a meaningful difference if
you're doing something you really like I
love what I do it's I won't say it's a
very difficult job because of all the
factors that we face all over the world
there's not a single exhaustion as
factory that doesn't affect an industry
I guess we're always working with that
but you're right my foundation is the
energy that I've derived from my people
and that's what I love to do it's why I
chose to come here from CSX that's why I
choose to continue that's why I chose to
come back from Dana almost died right I
mean who comes back from the heart
transplant to do this stuff well again
it's just who I am
and it's good to know that because
you'll have decisions in your life
they'll require you to make some tough
decisions you can go read all the books
and talk to all your wonderful professor
all the advisers all the counseling you
could possibly get the man it always
comes back to you and so it's a great
it's a and it's great you're you're
great you're the best at it about making
decisions for yourself but this is still
Silicon Valley so I do have to ask a
question about the future you have
worked in travel and transportation for
many years now and my question is what
do you think will be different about the
transportation industry say 20 years
from now oh gosh it'll be completely
radically changed right I mean from I
mean I just I hosted Daraa from uber and
a guy named Dennis Muhlenberg who runs
Boeing he goes no darling Daraa and
Oskar we have some first name people out
there and so mostly because DARS last
name is literally unpronounceable but I
had them both at an event down in San
Diego we talked about the future of
Transportation and when you hear them
talk about you know airplanes that fly
in space to literally flying cars they
both ones building the software ones
building the actual vehicle that can do
that so the Jetsons if you're somebody
remember those cartoons a long time ago
I've read about them I just somebody and
so there's just so much technology
that's going to be in our future I think
the way I approach technology is twofold
one whatever's new whatever's hot
whatever is applicable to us
let's roll I mean we've got Palantir
here in the valley we came out and
visited about a year and a half ago and
interviewed all sorts of different folks
with all these great technology you know
Big Data artificial until all those
wonderful buzzwords they can they can do
that I'm looking for things that are
relevant it's I call it relevant
innovation or relevant technology that's
relevant to you my customer today 50
years from now ten years from now
there'll be something more I don't want
to wait for you for five or ten or 50
years to be my customer I want you to be
my customer now so what is it that I can
do that's really healthy and worthwhile
for you so I have things we know so much
about you in a non-creepy way
I know all your flights I know whether
you've been upgraded I no way I know how
your flight went and so I have an app
and they were that when I sit next to
you I know all that I know your last
five flights and I know everybody's
sitting around in before I get on an
aircraft I check every one and when I
see it's red yellow green as simple as
that and it says I don't say oh there's
here's a red hey you flew from San
Francisco back to Chicago a month and a
half ago sir
sorry about that you know do you want to
tell me it's why I bring it up and
they're like you know like whoa well you
know I don't even remember the flight
but no and no but you start a
conversation but the fact that's it's
that personalization that's important so
take that conversation and make it even
better so I know all of that about you
so why can't I call you if you're a
traveling road warrior the person why
can't I call you on a Thursday evening
when you're leaving on a Friday and what
are the stressors right traffic parking
security upgrades all of those things
right are you on time all that sort of
stuff well I have enough data to be able
to proactively call you on a Thursday
afternoon and say hey ma'am I've seen
that over the last five flights we
haven't been able to upgrade you you're
a valued customer I want you to know
that a you have your upgrade B and I'm
working with TSA on this I well I'm
gonna get you through security at a
different line and by the way because
we're partners with lift provide lyft
uber and lyft here's a code for your
Oberer so you have a car you have
security and you have your upgrade the
night before you're going on a flight
how better do you sleep that night now
again for all of you to travel a lot you
recognize that but that to me is
relevant technology and that's how you
put art you know all this big data and
management there up how you put it to
use
not for this grandiose how do I extract
more revenue from you and I which is
important and we'll do that concurrently
but more importantly I want you
the business school right but again it's
it but it's a win-win right and so you
it's that's what I say I want you to
feel better about flying with me that's
something that you'll feel better
because like hey listen you know I was
kind of pissed cuz I haven't been
upgraded all of a sudden they called
ahead of time he knew what was going on
helped me out so that's a vision that
will worth working towards and so
technology is a great deal a great
advantage in all those places you just
it has to scale we are massive just so
big it's not even funny
so we have to make sure we do we're able
to work with some and the pound tear
Association was great
we've got Apple and Microsoft and
everyone else but we're always looking
for someone else too and so it's
exciting to see what's exciting that's
going on around here so you mentioned
your platform the platform that you've
been given as the CEO of United and I
want to transition to talking about some
of the larger things out in the world
that you have have played a role and
having conversations about including the
fact that United as a leader in its
efforts efforts to reduce carbon
emissions and recently committed to
having its emissions by 2050 but a
recent UN climate report suggests that
we only have until 2030 before we start
to see the catastrophic and irreversible
effects of warming so you're a leader
but Ken and should you do more well
reduce and officer I'll start with a
humorous approach and back to my SNL
Michael che said this he goes have you
heard the mean the planets dying in ten
years and then he says why don't I care
we don't owe and he goes on to say
humorously that's because you can't say
everything's gonna die because no one
cares about everything they care about
things that are on makes them you should
watch it's pretty funny
I'll tell you my evolution on this
personally and really as a company first
and foremost we burn four billion
you know gallons of jet fuel not regular
for jet fuel a year so carbon footprint
dude I have a giant you know size
whatever she shoe in that regard I also
made a business and a lot of money for a
lot of investors moving fossil fuels
coal for instance in the in the railroad
space and at that time it was sort of my
bias to disregard or disprove the
concept of global climate change and any
risk thereof I've evolved not because I
worked I mean I'm still having a big
carbon footprint I just see what we are
doing as a planet it we can't you just
can't deny the fact that the Hauer
whether it's industrialization whether
it's all the different things that we're
doing are creating a bigger risk this
planet will burst at some point I don't
know what it is so the question is Al
Gore then my conversations with them and
it's simple he says do you believe in
climate change and can you do something
about it and will you do something about
it
and so for me and I think for our
company do we believe it's real yeah I
think so yeah you know I can argue the
cyclical nature of global warming and
cooling over many centuries and all of
that but the difference is man-made
emissions are becoming more prevalent
and more impactful so yes I believe in
and we believe it as a company can you
do something about it I don't know we've
burned for billions of fuel can we
really do something it's like yes you
can so biofuels already are at their
infancy but were the leading posted to
invest in companies that manufacture it
we just flew from from here to Zurich a
couple weeks ago on fossil fuel it is it
isn't quite scale or economic enough but
our 2050 mission to your question is a
way it's just it's gonna take a while
and but
will you do something about it I we are
choosing that that's gonna be done and
what's cool about it because California
anointed surfing as their capitals
they're the state sport album which I
did a lot of that so I was very happy so
our president Jenna lampkins here had a
great idea why don't we fly surfboards
free and as a it's a complete different
gesture guess who picks up on that yeah
there you go
somebody I know for the skiers will have
to work on that but it's it has all
these so it's it's got its it's a it's a
long way away but you got to start
somewhere and by me doing it in this
industry hopefully folks a lot of heavy
carbon footprint companies to begin just
ask the question do you believe can you
do something and will you do something
about it
yeah immigration has also been a
hot-button issue and you have been vocal
you have come out in support of daca you
also refuse to let the US government fly
immigrant children who had been
separated from their families at the
border on any United flight what
responsibilities do executives of public
companies have when it comes to taking a
stand on these social and political
issues I mentioned the profitable but
principled earlier my opinion and I do
it on the basis of the strength of what
we've been doing in the business and
creating shareholder value creating
customer value and on that foundation of
accomplishment and success in the terms
that some people want to look at it I
see a responsibility we see a
responsibility my employees see a duty
by the nature of shared purpose and
uniting the shared purpose of connecting
people in uniting the world and I have
every freedom from our corporation to do
what we think is the right thing and
what's hard about it is that it is not
without its without its issues right I
mean you take a position on anything
nowadays and the social media world
lights up with negative you know haters
are gonna hate and boy do they and so
immigration and things immigrant you
know and things like that you know a
piece of my heritage become identity
politics right so you're quickly
discontinued
things are taken out of context all the
time but you know what if we're not
building and showing our next generation
of leaders that you are in this room
that you should be certainly profitable
but principal that we shouldn't think
about those social causes regardless of
what they are whatever extreme that you
can't voice it and I'm always very
careful to not make pronouncements that
are my bias there you know if it's my
opinion you will know that it's my
opinion but there's just it's we teach a
lot of things ethics and morals and
values I'm telling you the intersection
that you come to a fork in the road
where you have to make a decision on
something is a difficult one and it's
situational you know I don't I don't
have a problem with guns or anything I
just whatever your choice is but when
there's a shooting and one of your
pilot's a family member loses a daughter
who's 14 years old I can't stand by and
say nothing I won't stand by and say
nothing and despite you know one person
came to our annual meeting and just
berated me Warren Buffett said this how
dare you as a CEO take a personal
approach that you said it was I said you
know it had nothing to do with politics
it had nothing to do with guns that was
purely personal somebody lost a loved
one I can't stand by a long standby and
I and the team that did the family that
I belong to won't let that happen either
and so I think we need more of that
thoughtful not so much identity products
not so much buys but you know what on
the right things we have a big crisis
coming with this caravan coming I mean
you know the social economic instability
around us is awful this this world is
interconnected you know that because
you're growing up in an environment it's
so interconnected that something
happened it's gonna affect the US and
there's gonna be all hell to pay so we
will continue to work with all the right
folks to see anything that we can add to
that the political issues immigration
policies that will let politicians
manage with that I'm just there to pick
up whatever pieces I can and I have the
full support of my United family and our
board and I think that's important to
have but again importantly you build
that level of credibility you build that
goodwill by doing the things that you're
all learning to do here right strategy
involvement leadership
all those sorts of things but there's a
such a big human component to all of
this and don't ever forget that know who
you are
put yourself in the right situations
because you will face decisions in your
life like I said before what you have to
choose and how you choose and when you
choose there will be detractors there's
no question but so damn the torpedoes
let's just do it I mean I haven't I mean
I am fortunate to be in that position
that what are you gonna do it's like you
send me home to my family that I don't
see very often gosh
my wife well you have something to say
about that so I wanna I want to sneak in
one more quick question before we turn
it over to the audience here we have a
class coming in here soon so yeah one of
the questions we often reflect on here
at the GSB and and that I think a lot
about is this question of why should
people follow you how do you respond to
that question why should people fall on
you I think I have all these little
silly things I always say proof and I
promise it's like listen I'll stand in
front of you I'm gonna tell you what
we're gonna do and then you don't have
to do a darn thing because all you're
gonna see is proof of what I just told
you and for the the time I've been here
I can honestly stand in front of my
entire United family and our share
owners increasingly in front of our
customers as we do more in that space
and I said is there anything ever I have
told you that we haven't delivered on
and it's hard to say that but I don't
say things publicly that we're not going
to deliver on we're very careful and
review everything we're gonna we're
gonna say but it's important that's how
that's why people follow you because
they talk to each other you telling
someone you need to follow me because
I'm the man I'm the boss or I'm the
smarter I did all these things in this
other company all that's part of the
equation but every human needs a
personal connection a personal desire a
heart and a mind connection that drives
someone to what I generally call you
know discretionary effort this is a
business where you know I have 90 that
spread all over the world a gate agent
back in the back corner of some airport
and
you know in Turkey I have no control
over her and what she's doing all I have
is the communications that we've done
the feeling of family the shared purpose
and mission all of those superlatives
and all those things that people do in
business because then that person just
like when raising children once you know
your are your parents have let you go
mostly and you're left to make your own
decisions are you making the right
decisions some yes some not and so the
why you should follow me is not a
question I ask it's like let me show you
let me prove to you and then people
follow in droves I mean they really do
it's a really powerful thing when you
capture the hearts and minds of folks
how you do it versus how I do it that's
what you have to figure out because
there's no one way of doing it and you
have a lot of talented folks and faculty
that'll tell you all those different
things but my view is got to know who
you are
and for God's sake another thing I said
is swing easy we try too hard sometimes
I mean guys in particular you know they
could do boys when you ask a question
well let me tell you sir like relax and
I say swing easy because if you if you
play golf particular tennis if you see
the professionals they make that efforts
you know effortless right their swing is
effortless we in our career sometimes
try a little too hard especially early
on be the person that someone pulls
aside and says hey Oscar you might want
to try this versus that right you got to
be that person that people are willing
to if I have a guiding principle or a
fact of something that's been done that
I've been so fortunate at is that a
wrong across my career someone's always
pulled you aside especially when you
thought you were all that right I've
been you know my own I was youngest of
this and the youngest of that and all
that but then somebody key point if I
could one basa
it's just a it's a pointed story I'm
sitting at a review I just I'm a 26 year
old kid I went from this level at one
company to this level at coca-cola and
I'm just feeling everything and I think
everyone around me is kind of stupid cuz
you know I'm the smartest thing in the
world six months in my boss pulls mean
we have this performance review and he
says all these wonder hey your exceeder
expectations I took a risk on you you
know you've been killing it really
you're crushing it before that word was
important then he says then he closes
kind of the book and he pulls us out
because but if I could tell you
something on a more personal basis and
I'm like he wants me to date his
daughter or something probably now he
said and this is critical he said you
know what you're really good but you're
not yet good as good as you think you
are and I like excuse me that sounded
kind of like negative and and just you
know it's like you're not yet as good as
you think you are and I walked out of
there went through all those seven
stages of anger denial all those things
that people do but it was critical in a
long life you got to find the right
person that has that desire remember
sharing is caring and that made a huge
difference because I had walked into an
environment where I thought I was all
about I was the youngest than everything
well I recognized the people around me
were incredibly deeply knowledgeable and
experienced in phases where my energy
could be better affected and it's guided
me many things like that so always make
sure and and and don't ask people like
hey tell me something bad about myself
right you just gotta act that way and
find people love people around you give
them the Liberty give them the Liberty
to be honest with you you will find more
often than not when somebody tells you
something negative and you go hey honey
this jerk at work so this about me and
yours possible well honey that's an
important thing so ya know we'd like to
take a few questions audience if that's
okay
hi my name is Edward Silva I think your
Oscar I'm gonna be a student here at the
GSB and my question is where was the
United do the new creative even crazy
ideas come from and what are you doing
specifically to foster them um they want
to come from this listening thing
it's amazing how there's really cool
leading-edge innovation and there's just
basic things that we just need to do
right and better and so most of our
people focus on the latter it's like
just simple things like this boarding
thing I discussed and so getting input
from that on the innovation side we we
started what all of you around here know
but it isn't often as prevalent and big
hundred-year-old industrial companies
like mine the concept of fast failure
right big companies employ people like
you to do all the analytics and this and
all the studies and all these things and
about an idea and you go months into it
and then somebody determines it's a go
or a no-go and then maybe you try it or
you don't
but you've wasted so much time it's like
somebody has kind of a cool idea as I go
and so we built a digital sort of group
it's actually a separate building just
for many reasons but you go in there and
it's the objective and network in those
rooms it's just bringing ideas put them
to and then bring them up and see how
well they scale and it's amazing how
many things take hold but how energetic
that is and now in our company it's cool
to come up with ideas before it was like
well management doesn't like it you're
talking back so part of it is culture
but also part of providing an
environment but more importantly acting
on that environment so once again back
to proof not promise it's like you know
what so if you have an idea and it's
come to you I am taking you everywhere I
go and showing your mug everywhere it's
like his idea this is the guy that did
and this is what he does I mean we have
so many wonderful histories that we tell
about our company so creating that
culture and all of you are probably more
familiar with it cuz if you live and
work around here that's kind of it's
it's easier to do that in a smaller
younger company hundred year old
companies just don't do that my the
tenure of my workforce the level of
education all of those things
our subject but never underestimate the
power of human caring human engagement
and human experience makes a big
difference especially when it comes time
to dealing with you as customers hi my
name is Jorge Cueto and I'm a first year
MBA my question is related to work
culture as well what do you think is
necessary to create a more inclusive
work environment for Latinos as well as
for people from other underrepresented
groups including women black people
LGBTQ people and undocumented immigrants
veterans veterans invisible disabilities
like autism the biggest and best
supporter I think of Special Olympics
that we come in United because I believe
in that whole breadth yes it's my
heritage of my naturalizer I'll tell you
diversity inclusion two words diversity
and inclusion there are two different
terms diversity has become we made
progress
it's numeric metric oriented progress I
have the largest percentage of female
pilots in the world in aviation yay its
8% but it's the best I'll relax right
now diversity is just not about numbers
how are my women of color for instance
but more importantly back to the other
word inclusive I go see my woman pilots
and I said hey yeah did you hear your
you're the largest percentage of the
industry do you think they celebrate
that no because when I asked my kids
what else could we do better there's
always a list of things and those lists
of things are on the inclusive aspect of
it right am i involved do you value me
these microaggressions of stopping
people it's like do you know that women
get cut off in meetings more than anyone
and you tell it to a guys like now how
does it happen
watch can you go back and watch like
dang we do do the we do things like that
and so part of the thing that we're
doing and Latinos but Tino's by the way
the Millennial thing we all talk about
guess what the demographic looks like
very soon of Millennials versus boomers
right my nose bigger next year 73
million versus 70
two million guess what the percentage of
Millennials are that are Latino in this
country almost half so I don't go tell
you you got to do this you got a higher
Latinos I tell you it is an economic
force that is of massive proportions why
Daraa from uber and Denis Muhlenberg
were in the meeting with me is because
they recognize that it's a a 2 plus
trillion dollar market Latinos are and
56 is in the transportation leisure
business so it's a right market right
where you're all looking for growth and
for your companies and also well you go
fish where the fish are and the fish
have a little spicy salsa next to them I
can say that
but it grows it comes across all
cultures and everything and so and so we
I am there's just so much to be done
I'll tell you and I'm talking about it
tonight in San Francisco with women in
the workplace my next mission is to some
degree as because we have one of the
highest percentage of women in the
workplace and we all again the numbers
all work out for us in a way not the
point
harassment sexual harassment for our
flight attendants for people is still an
issue there's still idiots that sit next
to people and think they can touch think
they can do and ask and say things that
they should and there's still people
that sit next to someone and don't want
to sit next to someone because of their
race color sex or creed those people
have no time no way or no business you
can go fly elsewhere because that's just
not something we're gonna do hard to do
in this in this market because I have to
remove them from the aircraft right and
then we have that whole other issue
so I'd like to close by doing a quick
lightning round if possible so this or
that style aisle or window window
because if you sit next to me I mean
aisle because if you sit next to me you
just get a B I mean people reach over
customers and employees will reach over
you stand in front of you so I always
have the window so I can just talk to
people and not disrupt my fellow plumb
flying person next to me and yes I do
fly my own airline all the time gotta
eat what you cook now airline executives
do that Coke or Pepsi oh no what Coke
was my last time so classic coke no
additives i watch what goes into other
products and swipe the stuff and regular
coke is at least may God made right its
natural it's sugar but planes or trains
I gotta go with my family planes
adventure or relaxation oh god adventure
I don't know what that other way I do
know what that one is
now after I've done some adventure
something Kardashian's of The Bachelor I
labeled that the fall of Western
civilization as we
NorCal or SoCal amis Oh cowboy yeah no
question love it up here I got engaged
here I went running walking jogging
Tillie I forget how hilly it is downtown
but the Sarah the st. Francis hotel is
what I got engaged and so it's always
brings a lot of memory the carnelian
room probably most of you don't even
remember he's to be the top of the be of
a tower that's when I started my way
through my I thought I was so confident
in my request to my wife to join me in
marriage that I couldn't get two words
out four sepals always be close in that
regard and of course the last one Delta
or American no I'm just kidding you
don't have to it has been a pleasure
speaking with you Oscar
please join me
[Applause]
[Music]